مع اقتراب موعد انتخابات منتصف الولايه
يسارع الحزبان الديمقراطي والجمهوري على
حد سواء الى تعبئه ناخبيهم في بنسلفانيا
حيث المعركه الانتخابيه النصفيه المصيريه
حضنت ولايه بنسلفانيا الرئيسيه ثلاثه
رؤساء قبل عمليه اختراع حاسمه ستضع اسس
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 20 24
اوباما مساندا الرئيس الحالي جو بايد
المقابل ترامب الذي لا يزال يتمتع بقبضه
قويه على الحزب الجمهوري وامام التجمع
حاشد من الجمهوريين يستهزئ الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على قله عدد
الناخبين في تجمع منافسه الديمقراطيين
الانتخابي بولايه بن سلمان
[موسيقى]
جدا بدا الامر وكانه حشد من 200 شخص
في المقابل نزل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى الساحه والمفارقه هنا انه كان يتجنب
في ما سبق اعتلاء المنصات لجمع تبرعات
لحزبه معتبرا ان انتخابات منتصف الولايه
ستكون لحظه فارقه في مصير الديمقراطيه
داخل الولايات المتحده
ومع مساعي الحزب الجمهوري للسيطره على
الكونجرس حذر الرئيس الامريكي السابق
باراك اوباما من ان سيطره الجمهوريين على
الكونجرس ستجعلهم ينتقمون من منافسهم
السياسيين في اشاره منه الى انهم قد
يعزلون الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
[موسيقى]
ومن المقرر ان تحدد انتخابات التجديد
النصفي الحزب الذي سوف يسيطر على الكونجرس
فهل ستكون من نصيب الحزب الديمقراطي الذي
يسعى جاهدا للاحتفاظ بالغالبيه الضئيله
التي يتمتع بها في الكونغرس ام من نصيب
الحزب الجمهوري الذي يحاول اعاده قبضته
على مجلس الشيوخ والنواب سلطان العربيه